Hello and welcome to Lesson 6. We're going to talk about loops. But more
importantly, you're going to learn something that you probably want to know.
Namely, how you can become a millionaire, even though if you think about it
right now, interest rates. Rates are very low. Get a measly 1% on your bank
account. And I don't know about you, but I don't have a lot of money right now.
All I have to invest is $100. But, I have a plan. Here's my plan. I'm going to
set my time machine to that specific point when my bank account has a million
dollars in it. Or maybe if I can't find my time machine, I'll just let myself
be cryogenically frozen and tell them to wake me up at that moment. All I
need to know now is to which date in the future to set my time machine. So,
that's what we're going to be writing a program for and that program's going to
be using loops. Because it has to keep on adding that interest to the bank
account until it reaches $1 million. How long do you think it's going to take?
100 years, 1,000 years, 10,000 years, or almost a million years? Let's take a guess.